Je vais bien je vais bien je vais bien maintenant abandonner
Melvin n'aime pas les autres
nous sommes venus pour découvrir les capacités de
déplacer des objets n'utilise que le pouvoir de son
esprit il a tellement à offrir au monde
et il y a tellement de potentiel  pour
lui tu te sens bien
sûr que maman ne s'améliore jamais
ton cœur a cessé de battre pendant plusieurs
minutes
tu as été certifié mort
allongé là à l'hôpital j'ai réalisé
quelque chose que je vais changer je vais
commencer à combattre le crime pas l'engagement mais
tu l'as compris oui je  je vais faire tout ce qu'il
faut ne plus boire plus de
pilules contre les mauvaises herbes Miller je pense même à
arrêter de me branler ouais je n'irais pas
aussi loin non
tu as commencé une guerre nous ne pouvons pas nous battre
il
ira bien hé cinq nous '  re
formation ici mère